we've got too much uncertainty from that
so what this means on the weekend
talking to investors talking to in
traders they just have no idea what
they're looking at as their next
catalyst in a financial market you have
certain triggers you look at it can tend
to be credit markets you can tend to get
excess discounts and equity markets you
get turning points you get positions
cleaned out in FX the problem today is
no traitor no portfolio manager is
skilled and experienced and qualified to
plot out how a pandemic is going to
affect the market so it's not just that
we need a circuit breaker from national
markets we need a circuit breaker for
the epidemic so that means that we're
heading towards recessions in many
economies around the world but we don't
even know whether that's the reset how
bad will the epidemic get I'm mark
cutting work Coble managing editor for
the markets live blog where you can get
all your updates on markets 24 hours a
day
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
we are introducing new york state clean
hand sanitizer made conveniently by the
state of new york
this is a superior product to products
now on the market World Health
Organization CDC all those people
suggest 60% alcohol content Purell
competitor to New York State clean 70
percent alcohol this is 75 percent our
current capacity is 100 thousand gallons
per week and we're going to be ramping
up we'll be providing this to
governmental agencies schools the MTA
prisons etc
[Music]
[Music]
please the story I'm trying to tell is a
story of timely and targeted and micro
forms of assistance not gargantuan
across the board throw money at the
problem which has never worked in the
past because we think we will get out of
this more than months thousands of women
in Mexico City are protesting against
gender-based violence to demand that the
government implements concrete measures
to ease the rise in femicide
gender-based killings and other forms of
violence
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
Mexico es como si to V Ramos en un
estado de Guerre estamos en una crisis
humanitarian pause la cantidad de
mujeres des Aparecida csa sanada's ENS
trend are so la estamos en un estado de
vulnerable era
Alma yo yo no se mas para que todo que
Ella near no snowsport aleste no es la
fuerza que necesitamos para hacer esto
para compartir la maestra historia que
vemos K I'm not showing in pomona the
protests have turned violent some
protesters started breaking and spray
painting buildings President Andres
Manuel Lopez Obrador had tried to
dismiss the protest actions against his
government as politically motivated but
the women are sending a strong message
this has nothing to do with politics it
has to do with the violence that women
in Mexico face daily
[Music]
[Applause]
then think people now pick the car ways
but this is basically the whole central
power South Africa and as being people
that took their own life just out of
hopelessness
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
the big concern now will be what's gonna
happen to Coachella and stagecoach if
you lose both of those you lose almost a
billion dollars of revenue in the valley
so everybody every city needs to be very
proactive of what they're gonna do to
try to compensate for this loss it's a
historic day for markets it's an
environment we've not seen since 2008
and perhaps even long before then for
many asset classes these are moves that
are unprecedented I think one of the
great concerns for markets the moment is
we don't actually know how this crisis
will play out in many ways it's not as
bad as 2008 in terms it's not a
financial market led crisis back then we
are truly worried about the financial
system collapsing whether you be able to
get cash out from your ATM tomorrow that
is not the case now most financial
institutions are well capitalized banks
are much more aware about how to provide
liquidity but there's a much more
worrying thing here the coronavirus
epidemic we've not traded something like
this in modern financial markets it
looks like it's an equivalent kind of
pandemic in terms of investors Minds
to the Spanish flu we've got too much
uncertainty from that so what this means
on the weekend talking to investors
talking to in traders they just have no
idea what they're looking at as their
next catalyst in a financial market you
have certain triggers you look at it can
tend to be credit markets you can tend
to get excess discounts in equity
markets you get turning points you get
positions cleaned out in FX the problem
today is no traitor no portfolio manager
is skilled and experienced and qualified
to plot out how a pandemic is going to
affect the market so it's not just that
we need a circuit breaker from national
markets we need a circuit breaker for
the epidemic so that means that we're
heading towards recessions in many
economies around the world but we don't
even know whether that's the reset how
bad will the epidemic get
I'm mark cut work couple managing editor
for the markets live blog where you can
get all your updates on markets 24 hours
a day
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
we are introducing new york state clean
hand sanitizer made conveniently by the
state of new york
this is a superior product to products
now on the market World Health
Organization CDC all those people
suggest 60% alcohol content Purell
competitor to New York State clean 70
percent alcohol this is 75 percent we
our current capacity is 100 thousand
gallons per week and we're going to be
ramping up we'll be providing this to
governmental agencies schools the MTA
prisons etc
[Music]
[Music]
Oh
[Music]
what's wrong hey you guys hear me back
there hey can you guys
did you just
bombs on stun
Oh Shelly
[Music]
berries it okay now Barry okay now no
but I'm talking about this is it see see
I mean
[Laughter]
hello
yeah well he wasn't supposed to come to
this breaking it certainly wasn't on his
schedule instead we were expecting to
see the vice president and other members
of the coronavirus task force but just a
few moments ago they came in they
swapped out the seal and now there's the
presidential seal on the selector and as
we are now expecting to see the
president any minute now of course this
is going to be his first public
appearance since that news broke that
several lawmakers who attended that
political conference the same one the
president also spoke at are now
self-quarantine because someone there
has tested positive for corona virus and
they are said to have interacted with
that person of course two events ball
makers are people who have interacted
extensively with the president in recent
days including just three hours ago on
airport from Florida after he have held
that political fundraiser earlier today
so we're waiting to see what the
president's not only going to say about
that but also Glo PD has spent the day
relief downplaying this accusing the
media of exaggerating these claims in
order to plunge in the stock market but
also making comments like saying that
this could be good for gas prices as
you've seen the latest developments play
out so there are a lot of questions
still about the administration's
response to this that we are expecting
him to appear alongside those members of
the core Nevarez task force and there
are still questions are attend to like
whether or not they're prepared for this
and if they've enough breeding machines
for people drug planters they're not
able to get some of them
that are made in China things like that
that are really pressing questions for
the president and the members of his
koruna virus task force
can I pop down guys Thanks
for
[Music]
but now where's like 38 early on
respected the president is going to give
out any minute apples are just ahead a
system that the great news that happened
to push back to 6:30 but we are still
expected president agree the president
first inferred with the past 48 audience
from identify there certainly didn't
even enter in delivered on Twitter
yes I understand I understand
it's drunk off the phone
[Music]
[Music]
first person coming to the past talking
not just about the service if once it
itself congressman game designer
response warrior English that sick
individual at that conference
that's when beats it wasn't exempt
Irishman games was actually on board Air
Force one that he discovered that he had
been in contact with that individual at
the CPAC conference date set by himself
in the aircraft for the rest of that
trip the president in addition to today
three things is going to continue his
focus on the economy and will be
inviting over to the White House Wall
Street executives on Wednesday to see if
we can talk to them off the ledge and
stop the market leading in the markets
it wasn't until congressman gates was
actually on board Air Force One that he
discovered he had made contact with an
individual at the CPAC when it meets
decided to sit by himself and not your
perception of the air breath in addition
to today's briefing the president will
have Wall Street executives over to the
White House they're trying to talk to
Jim on an alleged agency a rich stop
bleeding in the markets at the White
House President Trump with big concerns
about the corona virus and big concerns
about the American economy John Roberts
at the White House on connection
ordering a half
damn well better yeah
[Music]
[Music]
well debrief on down at 6:30
Thanks
yes
[Music]
and it travels down Thomasson
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
thank you very much we just attended a
very important task force meeting on the
virus that everybody is talking about
all over the world no matter where you
go that's what's on people's minds and
we are going to take care of and have
been taking care of the American public
and the American economy we are going to
be asking tomorrow we're seeing the
Senate we're going to be meeting with
House Republicans Mitch McConnell
everybody and discussing a possible
payroll tax cut or relief substantial
relief very substantial relief that's a
big that's a big number we're also going
to be talking about hourly wage earners
getting help so that they can be in a
position where they're not gonna ever
miss a paycheck we'll be working with
companies and small companies large
companies a lot of companies so that
they don't get penalized for something
that's not their fault it's not their
fault it's not our country's fault this
was something that we were thrown into
and we're gonna handle it and we have
been handling it very well the big
decision was early when we shut down our
borders were the first ones ever to do
that we've never done that in our
country before it would have a situation
that would be a lot more dire also we're
going to be seeing small business
administration and creating loans for
small businesses we're also working with
the industries including the airline
industry the cruise ship industry which
obviously will be hit we're working with
them very very strongly we want them to
travel we want people to travel to
certain locations and not to other
locations at this moment and hopefully
that will straighten out sooner rather
than later but we're working with the
industries and in particular those two
industries we're also talking to the
hotel industry in some places actually
will do well in some places probably
won't do well at all but we're working
also with the hotel industry but the
main thing is that we're taking care of
the American public and we will be
taking care of the American
and I really appreciate the
professionals behind me and the
professionals actually behind them in a
different room we have a tremendous team
and it's headed up by our great Vice
President Mike Pence and I want to thank
Mike because he's been working 24 hours
a day just about he has been working
very very hard very diligently and very
professionally and I want to thank him I
want to thank the team and I'll have
Mike say a few words thank you very much
thank you I thank you mr. president we
just completed today's meeting of the
White House coronavirus task force we
were had the opportunity to brief the
president today on a broad range of
issues and once again because of the
unprecedented action that President
Trump took in January suspending all
travel from China establishing travel
advisories for portions of South Korea
and Italy establishing screening of all
direct flights all passengers from all
airports Italy and South Korea we have
we have bought a considerable amount of
time according to all the health experts
to deal with the corona virus here in
the United States in fact as I stand
before you today the the risk of
contracting the corona virus to the
American public remains low and the risk
of serious disease among the American
public also remains low that being said
the President did deploy not just a
whole-of-government approach but also a
whole of America approach and last week
at the president's direction we met with
leaders in industries from nursing homes
to Airlines pharmaceutical companies
commercial labs and it's had great great
impact pharmaceutical companies are
already working literally around the
clock on the development of both
therapeutics that'll be medicines that
can bring relief to people that
the coronavirus and I know that how
pleased the president was to learn that
the commercial labs in this country led
by companies like LabCorp and quest have
already brought a test forward and are
taking that to market effective today
this week the president's direction will
be meeting with hospital CEOs health
insurance CEOs and all a building on top
of what the president will be announcing
tomorrow with regard to economic relief
for working Americans we also met today
in a conference call with forty-seven of
America's governors we're able to brief
them on the latest the progress that
we've made we were able to confirm with
them that testing is now available in
all state labs in every state in the
country over a million tests have been
distributed before the end of this week
another four million tests will be
distributed but as I said before with
the deployment of the commercial labs we
literally we literally are going to see
a a dramatic increase in the available
availability of testing and that's all a
direct result of the of the president's
leadership today in a few moments we
will we will outline community guidance
that dr. Burks and dr. Fauci will be
publishing presidents direction we're
going to be providing guidance about how
to keep your home safe how to keep your
business safe how to keep safe and
healthy at your school and we'll be
publishing that information and speaking
about that a brief word about the grand
princess the grand princess has has
docked this afternoon in Oakland
California at a commercial dock 25
children we were happy to learn through
the screening over the last two days the
25 children on the ship are all healthy
of the people that have contracted the
corona virus 21 in all of they're being
dealt with in
proper isolation working with health
authorities in California we hope before
the end of today to begin to disembark
California residents to Travis Air Force
Base in Miramar we've made arrangements
with Canada and the UK to to take their
passengers back they'll be transported
directly to the tarmac charter flights
home and tomorrow the remaining
passengers will be transported again
through very very carefully controlled
environments buses out to the tarmac and
and flown to military bases in Georgia
and Texas all the passengers will be
tested isolated as appropriate
quarantined as appropriate and I want to
express appreciation to the Governor of
California and his administration the
governor of Georgia the governor of
Texas for their strong cooperation with
us in resolving the issues around the
Grand Princess it has been a it has been
a partnership which the president
directed us from the very beginning in
the process that Bob Kadlec will detail
in any questions in a few moments
continues to work and move forward the
remaining people on the ship the crew
itself will will push off from the dock
and they will be quarantined and
observed and treated shipboard but the
president made the priority to get get
the Americans ashore and we're in the
process of doing that as well as
returning foreign nationals let me just
say one other point is the president's
has spoken today to congressional
leadership one of the things that I
informed the president that I've been
hearing from governors is the concern
about hourly wage earners in this
country feeling that they had to go to
work even if they were ill and the
president has tasked this economic team
and is working already with leaders in
the Congress
to make sure that that that that anyone
is not feels that they are at risk of
losing their job or losing a paycheck
because they may contract the corona
virus when we tell people if you're sick
stay home
and the president has tasked the team
with developing economic policies that
will will make it very very clear that
we're going to stand by those
hardworking Americans stand by those
businesses large and small and make it
possible for us as the president said
from the very beginning put the health
of America first will be available to
take any questions on any of these
topics but mr. president I didn't know
if you wanted to we will be doing is
having the news conference tomorrow to
talk about various things that we're
doing economically they'll be very major
including obviously the payroll tax cut
and so we'll be meeting again tomorrow
afternoon it will be coming back from
the Senate we have a lot of very
important meetings set up and we'll have
a press conference sometime after that
and we'll explain what we're doing on an
economic standpoint and from an economic
standpoint but they will be very very
dramatic and we have a great economy
we're a very strong economy but this
came this blindsided
the world and I think we've handled it
very very well I think they've done a
great job the people behind me have done
a great job so I will be here tomorrow
afternoon to let you know about some of
the economic steps we're taking which
will be major thank you very much
Thank You mr. president
I have not been tested for the thrill of
a let me be sure and get you an answer
that I honestly don't know the answer to
the question but we'll refer that
question and we will get you an answer
from the White House physician very
quickly let me let me ask dr. Fauci and
dr. Burks to come to the podium you all
and the American public will have at
their fingertips very quickly guidance
then this is for every American we're
working with communities like the
Seattle area like portions of California
New York and Florida that have what we
call community spread a concentration of
coronavirus cases but we directed our
team to come up with helpful
recommendations for every American every
American family every American business
in school and if dr. Burks and dr. Fauci
step forward they can outline that for
you great thank you good evening we've
been it was good without getting out
last week meeting with communities we
know that the real solutions to this is
every American has a role in stopping
the spread of the virus and so we wanted
to really put out guidance for every
American in every community that was
practical and common-sense but detailed
in a way that everyone would know
precisely what to do the guidance will
be around how to keep workplaces safe
how to keep schools safe how to keep the
home safe and how to keep commercial
businesses safe where people would eat
or be present the importance about this
is we believe that communities are at
the center of this I came from a field
where it was the communities that really
solved our issues around HIV prevention
and so we're very much speaking to the
communities and the American people
about what can be done all of this
information came from a paper that dr.
pouchy provide
from The Australian's first also author
Dalton so you can actually look up the
scientific evidence that informed each
of these guidelines but we will be
providing that this evening in great
detail so that every mother father child
son daughter caregiver will know
precisely what to do and what to ask for
just to reiterate with dr. Burke said it
was as simple as that we have been
speaking about the kinds of things that
would keep our citizens safe in a
variety of environments we've been
speaking about on telephone calls we've
been speaking about at conferences the
CDC has been talking about this for a
long time as has dr. Burks and I so we
thought we would put it together in in a
neat form way that would be available to
the general public what dr. Burks had
mentioned is that just the other day I
got of one of many many emails where
some of my colleagues that I know from
Australia actually decided they were
going to write a paper on it and make a
number of boxes which was exactly saying
what we had been talking about so we
came up with the idea it would be very
good for clarity so why don't we just
put it together edit it a little and put
it in a way that people can look what
about the home what about the school
what about the workplace these are
really simple low-tech things there's
nothing in there that's complicated but
it's just stated in a way that's clear
that people can understand well one
thing I want folks to know is that we
have been looking at the data from
around the world and we now know more
than we ever have about who is at risk
who is at risk and I hope you will help
us communicate this to the American
people our people over the age of 60
they're much more likely to develop
complications from the corona virus and
to be hospitalized from the corona virus
the average age of death is age 80 now
what we also want communities to know is
that if you are a child or young adult
you are much more and more likely to die
from the flu if you get it then you
ought to die from corona virus so there
is something about being young that is
detective we want people to be reassured
by that we want people to know that we
are really focusing in on those those
groups that are at highest risk for
complications and helping them
understand how to be safe and this new
advice that's going to be coming out
tomorrow is designed to keep our
community safe to help keep the most
vulnerable safe and it's important to
understand that even though young people
aren't at risk for dying from
coronavirus they can potentially spread
that to older people in the communities
and people with chronic diseases so it's
important we all take precautions
washing our hands covering our COFF
keeping our distance from people who are
sick and taking the steps that will be
coming out in this new guidance to help
make sure we're doing everything we know
possible to keep our most vulnerable
protected thank you and I'm gonna I
think the Surgeon General raises a very
important point you know my mother is 88
years young my stepfather's about the
same age this is just a really good time
with doctor foul she tells us what the
experts tell us is is to look after look
after family members loved ones who are
senior citizens and particularly those
who have serious underlying health
conditions all the data dr. Burks
confirms to us that they they're the
most vulnerable to serious consequences
if they contract the corona virus but
the guidance that we would we would ask
members of the media and the American
public looking on you can go to
coronavirus gov this information to be
posted tonight and hopefully it will be
useful helpful common sense for families
for schools for businesses and for
commercial establishments that that
welcome the public in justice just to
create the kind of practices that we
believe will mitigate the spread of the
corona virus across the country as a
whole but with regard to seniors I might
just ask Seema Varma to step up and
speak about last week at the president's
direction we raised the standards for
every nursing home in America
with regard to infectious disease and we
are deploying all 8,000 of our
inspectors in every state as we told the
governor's today to focus exclusively on
infectious disease compliance at our
nursing homes our hearts break for the
families at the Kirkland nursing home in
Seattle the loss of life has been
Grievous but we are we are sending the
message out working with our governor's
to make sure our nursing homes and
long-term care facilities have the
additional layer of protection against
the spread of the corona virus and maybe
we thank you Thank You mr. vice
president as he said that's exactly
where our focus is it's around infection
control and we're working with the
entire healthcare industry today we
issued more guidance to nursing homes
about really upping their screening of
people that are coming into the nursing
home and making sure that you know
they're gloved and they have mass so
that they so that we can protect people
that are in the nursing homes the other
thing that we're doing is because we
know that many of our senior citizens
are vulnerable we want to make sure that
they know that the Medicare program is
behind them and we're here to support
them we're letting our patients know
that they can get a coronavirus test and
that there is no cost sharing associated
with that for our seniors on the
Medicare program and we're also letting
them know that because of the
president's leadership over a year and a
half ago he took action to actually
extend more telehealth benefits to our
nation's seniors and this is a very
historic change that we made under the
president's leadership and so if they're
sick and they're ill they can call their
doctor they can Skype with their doctor
and Medicare will reimburse for those
services and we've also in our
conversations with governor's today
we've talked about I'm having telehealth
services also available in the Medicaid
program great let me let me invite Bob
Cadillac who is a Deputy Secretary of
HHS to come forward as well to fill us
in on the latest on the progress on the
Grand Princess thank you mister that is
dockside now and is going through a very
careful process of having Americans and
foreign nationals come off and everyone
will be tested thank you very much so
and yes we began our
medical operation to basically disembark
those passengers on Saturday we place
the medical crew on that boat to augment
the physicians and nurses they were
already on the ship
we basically ensured that the quarantine
on the boat and no isolation were being
enforced and then evaluated first the
children and those who were ill
identifying anyone who is severely ill
if possible when the boat arrived on
dockside today additional medical
personnel came on board and we can began
an orderly disembarkation our intent is
to basically disembark about half of the
passengers on the boat today and the
other half tomorrow and everyone will be
medically screened before they get off
if there's any question about their
physical or health
they'll be screened again more
additionally and then they'll be
transferred to one of those for
quarantine sites in the United States
Travis Air Force Base Miramar Naval
Naval Air Station
Lackland Air Force Base and Dobbins Air
Force Base in Georgia the foreign
passengers will be transferred the
Canadians will be taken back to Canada
and we're working with the United United
Kingdom to return their passengers back
to the United Kingdom but we're doing
this all in cooperation with the great
support of the state of California the
City of Oakland and with the support of
Department of Defense Department of
Homeland Security and the US Coast Guard
thank you great and on the subject of
testing we had a very good discussion
today as I mentioned with 47 governor's
and outlined for them all of the
different testing methods that are
available we have tests now in every
state lab in America but we're rapidly
expanding that and let me ask the
Secretary of HHS to give us the latest
on the availability of testing to the
American public and of the states great
Thank You mr. vice president so we
continue with our strategic plan at HHS
across all of the components represented
by many of the leaders here which is to
diagnose to treat to contain to mitigate
to research and communicate it's what we
do in a healthcare crisis situation one
element of that is the test which of
course CDC developed in record time
after getting the genetic sequence
posted from China
that then was available at CDC and from
that point on there was no individual
that a public health official needed to
get tested the CDC didn't have surplus
capacity to test but we've been moving
progressively to bring that test closer
and closer and closer to the patient and
to the bedside and to make it as easy as
possible for us to use testing very much
in line with our peer countries facing
similar epidemiological circumstances at
this point we as many of you who are
here on Saturday for the briefing know
we have over 1 million tests that have
shipped from CDC and to private
contractors that are the CDC type of
test those are now out and as the vice
president mentioned every state public
health lab is validated and operating
those tests in addition hundreds of
thousands of those tests are in
hospitals in private labs in commercial
labs we we now have a total of 2.1
million tests that are available either
shipped or waiting to be shipped or
waiting to be ordered we by the end of
this week expect to be able to be
producing up to four million tests per
week in the United States and that is on
top of what the private commercial
entities the companies you know of like
LabCorp or Quest using their technology
the tests that they're getting out which
is an even better experience for the
patient because those were they are able
to actually collect samples directly in
doctors offices have a very
sophisticated collection system to their
labs again making it a very much more
seamless patient experience they're now
validated and getting up and running and
that you'll see even more of that so as
I said over the next week or so you're
just gonna see a progressively better
patient and physician and provider
experience connected to diagnostic
testing here in the United States
questions in just a moment we'll come
back we'll come back with that I want to
I want to invite the director of CDC to
come forward just to give you an
overview of where we are in the country
with regard to cases and and then we'll
take a question
any of the topics Thank You mr. vice
president we do continue to see an
increased number in cases again as we
said we would as as time passes we're
currently have over 500 cases now in the
United States outside of the
repatriation cases and the cases on the
diamond princess
we now have cases in 35 states that have
been reported in the District of
Columbia I want to reiterate what the
vice president said despite what I just
said here is that the present time the
risk the American public does remain low
we do have several community outbreaks
which we're focusing on in the Seattle
area in the Santa Clara California area
in Westminster in New York and in in
Florida and these are areas that we're
investigating heavily to try to
understand the transmission mechanisms
there and begin to help these
jurisdictions begin to operationalize a
series of mitigation strategies to help
against a slow and contain the outbreak
thank you and let me say just before we
go to questions coronavirus go for the
American public for health care
professionals it is a comprehensive
website we're adding to it every day and
also dr. Burks
we're working very diligently to
establish a single website where we
where people can go to track all of the
cases and where they're emerging
questions yes you and secretary notion
of like put a huge slide today and
people on Wall Street now talking about
the possibility of recession some people
saying it's a better than 50/50 chance
that that will happen how worried are
you that that will happen well let me
just first say today was an
unprecedented move in the oil market so
you know we saw a overnight reaction of
over down 20% and that's obviously what
had a major component today on the stock
market but let me just make a couple of
comments more broadly about the economy
first of all we couldn't be more pleased
that coming into the situation with the
coronavirus the US has with the most
resilient economy in the world
you saw a very large economic job
number last month and we couldn't be
more pleased that the president's
economic programs of tax cuts regulatory
relief and trade have put the economy in
a very good position I would also just
say that I am in daily conversations
with Chair Powell we are committed and
we just had a meeting with the president
and the economic team the president is
committed that whatever support we need
to provide to the US economy we will use
all our tools working very closely with
the regulators the president has the
bank CEOs coming in this week we'll be
talking to them about what they can do
to help small businesses and companies
that are impacted so let me just again
emphasize our primary focus is there are
parts of the economy that are going to
be impacted
especially workers that need to be at
home hard-working people who are at home
under quarantine or taking care of their
family will be working on a program to
address that we will also be working
with small businesses who need liquidity
through SBA programs we're looking at
alternatives at the IRS we have large
tax payments coming up of providing
certain relief to to companies and
individuals for liquidity so the
president is a hundred percent committed
that we will provide whatever tools we
need that the economy will be in very
good shape a year from now this is not
like the financial crisis where we don't
know the end in sight this is about
providing proper tools and liquidity to
get through the next few months
well let me just say there are certain
authorities that the president has that
we can do on our own
and we've already catalogued those tools
we have a large group a sub task force
of Treasury and NEC working on this we
are also working with bipartisan
leadership on a whole range of
alternatives that we'll be discussing
with them tomorrow and as you know we we
had bipartisan agreement on the spending
deal we will use the same approach to
work with the leadership on the House
and the Senate on this you have not been
tested you said you don't know if the
president has been tested but today we
learned that the president has
interacted with two lawmakers who have
interacted with someone who is positive
for coronavirus so why not get tested
well I just simply don't know what the
White House position is recommended to
the president but I promise you we'll
get you that information look this is
obviously the White House position is
there directive is to see to the health
and well-being of the President of the
United States and we'll get you a very
direct answer on that but let me let me
just say to everyone I really do believe
that the guidance that we put out today
would be very helpful and very
encouraging to Americans it was
fashioned by dr. Burks dr. Fauci some of
the leading experts in infectious
disease in the world and for families
that are looking on tonight to go to
coronavirus gov you can find information
about how you can just make your home
safer your family safer your school
safer your business safer and we
recommend that to your attention
believe that what happened in the stock
market today we're seeing American
industry some of which the president
named today as being affected and in
trouble here are in any way a result
this White House's reaction to the
coronavirus crisis is this the markets
and American business is saying that you
guys are not enough well I have to tell
you I'm I'm about a week and a half into
being asked to lead the president's
White House coronavirus task force in
the men and women standing behind me and
all the men and women standing behind
them
have done a remarkable job responding to
this the president's decision to suspend
all travel from China
dr. Fauci I think reflected just last
night on national television about the
time that that bought us the decisive
action in declaring a public health
emergency I really do believe that the
American people concede that this
president is putting the health of the
American people first but make no
mistake about it as we go forward and
particularly as we have more testing
available we have these communities that
have community spread there there will
be more cases and but but we simply
asked we asked today for the American
public to join with us in the
common-sense practices that will
mitigate the spread of the coronavirus
and also particularly we're asking every
American to look after our seniors who
have serious underlying health issues
they are clearly the most vulnerable and
that's where the focus of our energy is
today even as we do everything that we
can working with governors at every
level state and local public health
officials to limit the spread if I could
ask you a question of dr. Carson
mr. president more and more
organizations charities are canceling
fundraising events other events is that
proven is that an overreaction do you
think the president should continue with
campaign rallies and do you believe that
people even if they're healthy should
get on board a cruise ship
okay so there's multiple different
questions John
so the idea about individual entities
governors mayors or whatever canceling
activities that are not coming from a
direct recommendation from the federal
government I think that they have a
theater I don't think I know they have
the authority to do that but what
they're probably acting on is what they
would consider for their citizens and
abundance of caution most of the time
when that happens it usually is in an
area where there is already documented
community spread and and dr. Redfield
mentioned the four areas right now that
are having community spread that's
documented but you know there may be as
we know it's a rillette so it's it's a
possibility that there's community
spread going on in areas in which we're
not detecting it yet and I think that's
the response of the individuals be they
mayor's or governors who have you who
are doing that so I wouldn't criticize
them for that they're using their own
individual judgment and to me I think
that that would be prudent you know I
can't comment on campaign rallies it
really depends it but we are having as
we've all said this is a something in
motion this is an evolving thing so not
sure what we're going to be able to say
at the time where you have a campaign
rally if you're talking about it
campaign rally tomorrow in a place where
there is no community spread I think the
judgment to have it might be a good
judgment if you want to talk about large
gatherings in a place where you have
community spread I think that's a
judgment call and if someone decides
they want to cancel it I wouldn't
publicly criticize them
last one about cruise ships because a
lot of people are planning cruises over
the spring break and you right Amanda
anybody even a healthy person on board
yeah I think if you're a healthy young
person that there is no reason if you
want to go on a cruise ship to go on a
cruise ship
personally I would never go on the
cruise ship because I don't like cruises
but that's another story but the fact
the fact is that would if you have if
you have the conditions that I've been
speaking about over and over again to
this group namely an individual who has
an underlying condition particularly an
elderly person that has underlying
condition I would recommend strongly
that they do not go on a cruise ship and
let me also say John I think you raise a
good point for we're expecting a
proposal tomorrow DHS the Coast Guard
all of our health officials are
currently discussing with the cruise
line industry I was in Miami on Saturday
we've made it very clear that we needed
cruise lines the to be safer to
establish and to embrace new protocols
screening onboard screening off new
medical protocols shipboard
processes for evacuating people that may
contract coronavirus or a serious
illness and and I know the president was
grateful that our cruise line leadership
all stepped up to the table they said
they're ready to go to the next level
and so we'll we'll be reviewing that
proposal tomorrow with the objective
that apart apart from the Americans the
doctor found she just described the
seniors with serious underlying
conditions we're going to work with the
cruise line industry to improve the
safety improve the health environment on
cruise lines in the short term and in
the long term yes
last time president Trump was in this
room he told us that the number of us
cases was 1,500 students going down to
zero you guys are saying today that the
number is going up and it's more than
500 what is the discrepancy and how was
he so wrong on that oh look I think what
the president was referring to is that
we will have people that test positive
and then they get better President Trump
wants the American people to know and
I'm going to ask dr. Burks to reflect on
this for a moment the vast majority of
people who contract the coronavirus will
get better and the president has just
challenged our task force as the numbers
grow and they will as we will continue
to test more and more Americans we are
as I'm standing here that it's also
important to remember that people with
the vast majority get better
completely some some large percentage
have mild flu symptoms some have serious
flu symptoms but then of course for the
for the Americans you heard the Surgeon
General refer to seniors with underlying
serious health conditions doctor foul
she referred to we're committed to lean
in and to make sure they have the
support they need but but the
president's focus here is just making
sure people understand that while the
numbers grow there are people that come
off the list because they get better and
dr. Burke sir do you want to reflect on
what we know about the cycle of the
corona virus yeah thank you so we know
the corona virus reacts a lot like the
flu in the way it spreads and in the way
we prevent it and so when we cut out the
guidelines to the American people they
will reinforce the guidelines and we
hope the number of flu cases go down too
because people will really be Scituate
what we call situational awareness I did
want to add one piece to our cautions
about people with pre-existing condition
we also know that there are children
with pre-existing conditions and we know
that there are individuals that are
undergoing chemotherapy for their
treatment of cancer
for those individuals if they have what
we call decreased number of white cells
and they will have that discussions with
the doctors they are given often a sheet
of paper that really describes how they
need to protect themselves and how their
family needs to protect them so I want
to make sure that we understand
yes we're concerned about the elderly
we're concerned about others with
pre-existing condition we're also
concerned about anybody who may be in an
immuno at what we call an
immunodeficiency state having less white
cells and less able to combat any virus
we want to protect all of them from the
flu and we want to protect all of them
from corona virus and that's why these
guidelines are particularly important
journalists in the room do what you can
to distribute this information
coronavirus gov because exactly the
reason that dr. Burks just said so well
that we want to make sure that families
have the tools businesses have the tools
even in areas where we don't have a
significant outbreak at the corona virus
we want to make sure that the American
people have the tools to prevent the
spread of the corona virus particularly
with regard to the most vulnerable you
tell us how many Americans have already
been tested and as a follow-up to a
question was asked earlier are the
president's tweets hurting your efforts
at all because he's accused of Democrats
and some of the members of the press of
making more of this than then he says it
is he's made lighter of it then you all
have here so as his tweets hurt you and
can you please tell us how many
Americans have been I'm happy to do that
but the president's leadership has made
the difference here I heard it again
today from 47 governor's governor Larry
Hogan joined me in the Situation Room
he's the chairman of the National
Governors Association I think every
American would be inspired if you could
see the way under the president's
leadership and in cooperation with
governors in every state in every
territory we literally are working
seamlessly on behalf of the
all of the American people I'm going to
invite the Secretary of HHS to come up
and speak about how the number of tests
that have been done and where we are and
the tests that are available he's
addressed but in terms of those that
have been conducted so we've told you
we'll tell you what we know and what we
don't know okay so they're different
types of tests that get sent out the
cdc's tests that CDC is sending out
that's that 70 then enough to test
75,000 people that was sent out last
week those go to public health labs
about 80 labs in the United States one
in each state at least those report
results back in to the CDC because
they're part of the public health
network the larger quantity of tests
that shipped about 900,000 of the tests
that shipped by this weekend and then so
many of the remainder of that two point
total 2.1 million test those go to
hospitals private labs others for
testing they don't currently have to
report to us that they've conducted a
test or what the result of that test is
the CDC is actively working right now to
build that in that that IT connectivity
with them so we can gather that
information so right now I could not
give you a number of how many Americans
have received a test because many will
have received a test through hospitals
or non public health labs and so let's
let's work we're getting the system the
IT system up through CDC we want to give
you accurate information as we go we'll
be back here tomorrow and we'll continue
to bring the latest information forward
to the American people again let me
encourage all of you here and everyone
looking on around the country to go to
coronavirus gov get really useful
practical common-sense recommendations
about how to make your home safer how to
make your school safer how to make your
business and in any enterprise out there
safer these are these are practical
recommendations from the Ben
experts in America and we commend them
to your attention but let me also just
have a word of encouragement to everyone
I want to say again all of our medical
experts apart from the areas where we
have community spread and we're focusing
resource the risk of contracting the
coronavirus for the average American
remains low it will remain that way more
so if all of us continue to practice
common sense habits in our home in our
businesses in our schools in our public
institutions and so it's important to
remember what President Trump said we're
all in this together it's not just going
to be a whole-of-government approach
it's a whole of America approach and and
together
we'll get through the coronavirus again
details on all the latest information
coronavirus gov thank you
[Music]
[Music]